hey you guys welcome to flickers of fear
now remember a few months ago i think it
was march when i did like a theme i did
like monster march and i think i said
back then that i wasn't going to do a
theme for a couple of months because it
was a bunch of movies that i wanted to
catch up on but that i would eventually
get around to doing some themes again
while that time has now arrived because
now we're in july and i've been wanting
to i was actually going to do this last
month but then i was like well it still
works for this month too so this month
we're gonna do diallo july so we're
gonna do all uh all the flickers of fear
are going to be jello movies uh ones
that i haven't covered so far
so hopefully y'all are as excited about
it as i am uh because yeah i'm really
into this now most of the ones that i'm
gonna do um are gonna be you know giallo
era ones like from the 70s and stuff but
there are a couple of new ones in there
including the one that i'm talking about
today
now
if you don't know i mean most of you uh
know me right so you know that i am like
a massive massive fan of jello movies
just the whole vibe of them the whole
look of them
it just like takes me to a happy place i
don't even know what it is about them
there's just something i really really
like about them and always have so as
much as i love you know all the old ones
all the classics and stuff like that i
will say that um i can't help but have a
little squeal of excitement whenever a
modern filmmaker
uh shares my obsession with giallo
movies enough that they're like okay
well i'm gonna make like a modern-day
gela movie like whether it's full-on
giallo or whether it's just kind of like
jello tinged um it's just that's fine
with me i just love that whole aesthetic
so i think i've covered like a few other
i guess what would be considered like
neo giallo movies uh on this series
before
uh in fabric which is fantastic
barbarian sound studio uh the neon demon
which i guess is sort of like at least
has that similar kind of aesthetic even
though it's not strictly a giallo
um and i think i don't think i talked
about on flickers of fear but i think we
talked about it a long time ago on
matinee but there was a movie that came
out it's canadian and it came out back
in 2014 which is called the editor and
it's like a giallo
parody slash loving homage and it's
fantastic i [ __ ] love that movie so i
think it's on to be now if you want to
watch that one um i might cover that one
too again like um at some point because
like i said i think we talked about it
on matinee but i wouldn't mind doing
like a deeper dive on it the thing about
a lot of neo-gella movies though um is
that while a lot of them sort of take
the aspects of diallo that everybody
knows and loves like you know their
twisty murder mysteries they have these
really lurid like striking color
palettes um kind of bloody grotesque
operatic kind of kills they have like
jarring you know bizarre musical scores
that kind of stuff um but a lot of them
either put the story like in a modern
setting and just give it like a giallo
tinged flavor or they set them in the
past such as barbarian sound studio but
you can still tell that they're modern
movies like i said barbarian sound
studio is set back then like it's about
like the
filming of a giallo movie but you can
still tell that it's a modern movie the
so it's much rarer i think to see a
present-day giallo movie or you know at
least in the last decade or so that's
actually making every effort to look
like an actual lost giallo film from
back in the genre's heyday like of the
1970s
so in comes argentinian brothers luciano
and nicholas onetti
now these two guys uh one's a director
one's a screenwriter so they work
together
these two guys love glo movies so much
uh that pretty much ninety percent of
their filmmaking aesthetic because i
think they've made a couple other types
of movies too but most of their
filmmaking aesthetic is to try to make
movies that look
spookily like giallo movies that could
have come out in the early 1970s
they made one in 2013 called sono
profundo or deep sleep now i haven't
seen that one yet but i looked at the
poster like the cover for it and the
cover of it looks exactly like something
you would have seen advertising like one
of dario argento's movies like four
flies on great velvet or something like
that the design is just uh it's amazing
i love it so i'm gonna have to like
watch that one too so then in 2015 they
made francesca which is the movie that
we're talking about uh right here
this movie
looks so much like a 70s era giallo
movie that it just
delighted the [ __ ] out of me from the
very first frame also the poster art for
this one is rad as hell i totally want a
print of that i couldn't find one on
amazon i'm sure somebody sells them
because the poster art is just
beautiful i mean it's it's amazing
everything that you know is sort of like
classic to the genre is here there's the
killer with the leather gloves on
super saturated colors and like all
these kind of weird uh you know angles
and stuff like that these real queasy
like close-ups of inanimate objects like
doll heads and stuff like that big shiny
knife blades and spikes and that kind of
stuff whole thing about childhood trauma
like some stuff from childhood coming
back to like haunt you nowadays uh it
even has like the same font like for the
credits like the opening credits that a
lot of the uh old giallo movies used i
mean
spot on
also uh the bad out of sync like italian
dubbing they did that too
um
the ubiquitous bottles of j and b that
are like in the background like in
people's offices and apartments and
stuff which is what it's funny because
that's one thing i always noticed like
in jail because i'm like oh my god they
always have like jmb i don't know if
it's because
that's just like a really common uh you
know liquor to have in italy or if
because the the label's yellow i don't
really know what what the deal is but
they all have like bottles of jmb in the
background and they did that too like
everybody's apartments they always had a
jmb i was just like i see what you did
there i see what you did there uh it's
uncanny it's okay like how much this
looks like it uh there's even been like
some kind of filter or film grain or
something like that like to make the
movie look like not shitty but you can
tell it it very much looks like a movie
that would have come out back then like
it looks a little bit
rough but not like in a fakie sort of
way if that makes any sense it's really
incredible how much attention to detail
went into making francesca look as much
like a giallo from decades ago as
possible and i was totally there for it
i was like as soon as it started i was
just kind of like oh yeah okay i see
what you're doing so all that's great
jenny you might be saying but what the
[ __ ] is this movie about now
in the tradition of all the classics of
the genre it's a murder mystery so you
have like a bunch of red herrings you
have people with like really shifty
motivations you have seemingly
nonsensical plot threads and all of that
other kind of stuff that you would sort
of expect from a film of this kind
please note however that like many of
the giallo movies from the olden times
if you want to call it that the plot
isn't the most important aspect of the
movie
don't get me wrong there is one like
there is a plot uh and it does make
sense like when the mystery is resolved
but
on the whole i would kind of advise if
you're gonna watch this go into it more
as like a sensory experience um because
the visuals are really gorgeous it has
like this really unsettling score and
like really creepy like sound design and
just the over overall like ambience of
it is just like so so cool
um but like i said there is a mystery
there is a plot and stuff like that so
it's not like it's just completely
plotless but i don't think that that's
really the main
selling feature for it uh also note that
there is some dialogue wherever
necessary but it's pretty sparse you
know what i mean like there'll be like
several like long sequences where nobody
talks or it's just kind of like you know
what i mean so there's that kind of
stuff too
so at the very beginning of the movie
we're introduced to the visconti family
uh which is the mom whose name is nina i
think uh the dad whose name is vittorio
the daughter francesca who looks like
she's about maybe like 11 or 12. i
couldn't really tell
and there's like a baby boy like in this
little baby carriage
now from the jump you know that the kid
francesca is a bit of a miscreant
because
the first time you see her she's
stabbing like a dead bird like a pigeon
or something like that like a bird's
corpse with a big silver spike and like
laughing about it like yay we
destruction you know what i mean so it's
that kind of a situation
uh then [ __ ] escalates uh prodigiously
when uh not too long after that she
actually uses the same spike
to stab her baby brother
right in the [ __ ] eyeball
so you know as soon as her mom's back is
turned she just goes and there's wait
yeah somebody stabs a baby like in the
first five minutes of this [ __ ] movie
so there you go it's a giallo uh so then
like you kind of have the mom screaming
and screaming obviously uh as you would
now after this kind of opening sequence
we jump ahead 15 years
and we subsequently learn that francesca
was apparently kidnapped by a masked
home invader not too long after the
whole baby stabbing incident and she's
been missing ever since like there's
been no clue as to her whereabouts
francesca's dad vittorio
uh was stabbed in the spine like during
the attack he was kind of trying to
rescue her apparently and so but the
attacker like stabbed him in the back in
the spine
so he's now confined to a wheelchair
nina the mom uh understandably has never
really recovered from this whole tragedy
not only the baby stabbing but also then
the daughter disappearing uh so she's
like pretty much checked out she just
kind of like lays in bed she has this
like thousand-yard stare uh you know the
dad comes in and like gives her
medication every now and then so it's
not a good situation meanwhile uh on the
streets of rome
there begins to be a series of murders
perpetrated by a mysterious killer who
leaves like rare coins on the eyes of
the victims and plants these sort of
like cut up ransom style notes near the
bodies
uh that have quotes from dante's divine
comedy on them
now the first murder which is like a
young woman and she's just like left in
the middle of the day like in the
[ __ ] middle of a public park and this
older woman who's in the park walking
her dog like sees the killer dumping the
victim
and she describes the uh the killer to
the cops is like it looked like a woman
like clad in a kind of reddish orange
jacket some reddish orange leather
gloves a black skirt and a black hat and
veil which covered the face you couldn't
see who they were now as the bodies
start to pile up the two detectives who
are assigned to the case named suco and
moretti i think
they start to realize that most of the
victims
had some kind of like secret or some
kind of scandal in their past like there
was adultery or something like that like
along those lines
and they also start to slowly realize
that the killings actually might be
linked to the disappearance of francesca
visconti 15 years ago now because her
dad vic vittorio is a dante scholar or a
medieval you know whatever maybe like
medieval literature scholar scholar or
whatever so the police actually bring
him in on the investigation when they
figure out the these notes are from uh
dante or from divine comedy so they
bring him in on the investigation now as
the movie goes on it seems pretty clear
who the killer is but i will say that
the plot actually does have a couple of
surprises up its sleeve it really is
quite good at
misdirecting i think because honestly
i kind of like
i sort of figured it out but not exactly
and like the the twist at the end if
it's i don't even know if i want to call
it a twist necessarily but when it
happened at the end i was just like oh
okay i didn't see that coming i didn't
see that coming so you know maybe
smarter people than me would but i did
not see it coming so i was like okay i
see what you did there okay that's good
now uh oh i also want to say too that if
you're gonna watch it like make sure
that you watch until after the credits
are over because there's like a little
like post credit like a little creepy
kind of uh scene at the end a little
bonus scene
so i'm going to say if you're into like
the old school giallo movies uh you will
probably love this and you will just
like squee with delight it'd be like oh
my god like somebody made this like in
2015 and it looks just like an old movie
from like 1972. it's amazing
i mean it's an almost
dead-on recreation of just a classic
movie from that time period it's just
like eerie like how well they how well
they sort of like mocked it up you know
what i mean it's crazy
i mean just the artistry behind it this
whole like meticulous theming that they
did like everything that's in it like
all of the backgrounds all the clothing
it's like everything like that it's just
like perfect i mean it's just the whole
thing i was just the whole time i was
just like in awe i'm like wow that's
like that is such commitment and i love
that
um now i will say though that for those
that aren't really all that versed in
the sort of visual or auditory language
of the giallo
subgenre then i don't know
if you'll get as much out of it you know
like it might kind of be a harder sell
for somebody like that if you're not
really familiar with a lot of like
giallo type tropes or if you haven't
seen a bunch of other jlo movies you
might not appreciate it as much but i
don't really know because i'm not coming
at it from that place so it's you know
what do i know maybe people might still
like like it anyway just for being like
a weird ass you know retro throwback
kind of flick and it's still a mystery
you know what i mean um you know and the
mystery is decent and it's pretty well
constructed but i will say that like the
look and feel of the movie is really
where it shines which like i said i kind
of feel like that's true of a lot of
classic uh jellos as well
um but the whole vibe of it it's just so
like
otherworldly and it was like really
dreamlike it was almost like watching it
was almost like watching a movie almost
from another dimension kind of it was
just you know what i mean it's like
really hard to like put my finger on
just like the whole vibe of it but i got
like really swept up in it and it's just
gorgeous looking like i said there's not
this is when you really have to like sit
and like watch it because
you know there is a mystery there is
exposition and stuff but there's not a
huge amount of dialogue and a lot of it
is conveyed through
visuals uh so you really do have to like
pay attention
so
i mean i really liked this a lot so i'll
definitely be checking out uh the onetti
brothers other movies um i had just
there was an interview with them in rue
morg like a couple years back and i just
like read that before i did this and
it's like they seem like really nice
dudes there are other movies like aside
from uh sono profundo which i already
mentioned they also made another giallo
uh i think it was in 2018 although i'm
not sure if it got a wider release until
2019 or 2020 but that's called
abracadabra like with a k
and they've also kind of like branched
out and they did in 2017 they made i
guess it was like a more traditional
slasher like a really gory slasher um
that was called what the waters left
behind so i might want to check that one
out as well because i've also heard that
was really good i mean i'm just always
so ecstatic when i
kind of come across new
new to me at least like artists whose
stuff that like i vibe with so much so
i'm really glad that i sort of like
stumbled across this film i can't even
remember i think i saw it i was looking
for examples of
neo giallo like new jello movies and it
turned up on some list somewhere and i
was like oh that sounds good and then i
saw that it was on to be so i wrote it
down my list it was like oh yeah i got
to check that out and the poster is
incredible i love it so i was just kind
of like i'm really really glad that i
sort of stumbled across it and then when
i found out that they made a couple of
other giallo movies as well so i'm
definitely gonna have to check those out
i mean abracadabra sounds
awesome like cause that's also a giallo
but it's about like it's a magician and
i was just kind of like ooh magic oh
that's cool i'm gonna have to like watch
that too so yeah i'm totally gonna watch
that i think it's only 1.99 on amazon
prime so i might be getting into that
but yeah if you're really into jello
movies uh definitely check it out it's
it's just like so amazing like how well
they recreated like the whole like vibe
a bit and i was just there for it i
thought it was so cool but yeah so uh
anyway hopefully you guys will want to
see some more like giallo movies because
july we're doing all glow movies this
month on the flickers of fear show so
hopefully you'll tune in for the rest of
those and i will see you on the next one
bye